you make a comment about a guy that's  got 100 million twitter followers and  you're not on twitter he's on twitter  rogan a week ago just said he would  never have you on then musk says this  and you go after musk so let's just say  let's let's play this out  let's say trump is the candidate for the  republican side let's say he is let's  say he wins  you think musk is the kind of a guy that  would flip and say oh we have to vote  for trump  you think musk is all of a sudden going  to get behind trump we think muscle is  going to remember what he said when he  called him a [ __ ] artist what kind  of a wiring do you think mosque has do  you think musk is going to sit there and  say well let's get him in there or he's  going to say [ __ ] why are you putting me  in this guy you cornered musk to not  support you  that's why i said